[Music]
hey everybody it's Charlie Abba getting
a lot of questions about what captain
Marvel's powers are why is she so
powerful in why Kevin Feige has been
hyping her up is one of the most
powerful characters that they've ever
introduced into the movies so the
important thing to remember is is that
he is distinguishing between Avengers
characters and just characters in
general because like ego the Living
Planet is one of the most powerful
celestial beings that they've introduced
so they're not saying the Captain Marvel
is celestial level powerful that's more
of an eternal thing that we'll get into
in that movie but they're having a
couple of Celestials that we've seen
stomping around like during the first
guardians of the galaxy movie when we
saw Esau on the searcher this is what he
said during the interview where he's
quoted as talking about how powerful she
is so he says with Captain Marvel she's
as powerful a character as we've ever
put into a movie her powers are off the
charts and when she's introduced she
will be by far the strongest character
we've ever had
there's so much potential in the comics
and there have been so many incarnations
of her powers and the characters who've
had that mantle that we've been focusing
it on it exactly how to tell her origin
how does it fit into the cosmic side of
our universe how does it fit into what
we're doing with the next Avengers
movies he was referring to Avengers
infinity war in Avengers 4 when he meant
the next Avengers movies so what he's
saying is is that her backstory is
really complicated which is totally true
they won abroad in the Marvel cosmic
universe with the way they tell her
backstory and on a practical level
incorporate more cosmic level abilities
because of the way her powers work so no
surprise it took him a while to do that
on a basic level when she's in her human
form her standard abilities are
superhuman strength endurance stamina
flight physical durability limited
precognition you could call it her
version of spidey sense she can sense
when really bad stuff is about to happen
and because of the way her DNA was mixed
with Marvel's Kree DNA she also has
resilience against diseases and other
forms of pathogens the real reason why
she's more powerful than most of the
other characters save maybe Thor with
Stormbreaker
because remember he got a big power
upgrade in Ragnarok and Kevin Feige did
that interview before all that stuff
happened so the real reason is is
because of her
binary form when she becomes a near
cosmic level power tapping into the
white light of creation via white holes
so if you're not really into science a
white hole is kind of like the opposite
of a black hole in it's rumored to have
been the Big Bang people believed that
it was the energy of the Big Bang so
think about her tapping into the white
light of creation that formed the
universe that also formed and scattered
the Infinity stones is also part of the
way that ego manipulates cosmic energies
so think about it all flowing from the
same source the white light of creation
Like Heaven Feige said though her
backstory the way her powers work had
been very complicated and changed many
times with each retelling of her origin
story and are there a lot of theories
about how they're incorporating quantum
energy in the quantum realm into the way
the Avengers are able to move around and
use powers during Avengers 4 but think
of her powers is flowing from the same
source as the Infinity stones powers now
that doesn't mean that she's as powerful
as the Infinity Gauntlet that's
ridiculous it's just that it all flows
from the same source like everything had
to come from somewhere like Galactus is
a very popular character he's a relic of
a previous version of the universe
before it collapsed and reformed into
another Big Bang and it became what we
call the eighth firmament every many
billions of years something happens
there's an extinction-level event
everything dies collapses back down and
it really you never so like a cycle of
big bangs the Infinity stones and
Galactus are remnants of the previous
version of the universe so that's why
the Infinity stones contain the power of
an entire universe distilled down into
small stone form that's part of the
reason why they're able to affect the
universe on such a large scale when they
work together because you're basically
wielding an entire universe against
another universe the reason why the
quantum realm is so powerful is is
because it's sort of a singular layer
that exists across all universes within
the multiverse infinite universes but
only one quantum realm so it sounds like
what Kevin Feige is trying to tell us is
that on a limited scale she will have
the ability to tap into cosmic energy
which will endow her with powers that
are beyond what most of
characters have on a real basic level
dr. strange since the Doctor Strange
movie has been spending all of his time
studying so he's the most powerful
sorcerer in the universe but he has to
cast spells a lot of his abilities are
active like meaning that he actually has
to take action in order to use his
powers the really cool thing about
captain Marvel's powers is that they are
passive so even if Thanos tried to shoot
Captain Marvel in the back with the
Infinity Gauntlet she would be able to
soak and absorb that damage she absorbs
any kind of energy even magical energy
so like when Doctor Strange is fighting
Thanos in this giant wizard battle she'd
be able to absorb all that damage and
give it off as giant energy blast from
her fists or if she soaked enough damage
that would enable her to go into binary
form which would turn her into a more
cosmic level figure but like you would
expect because you kind of have to
balance the power scales you can't have
somebody that powerful just roll in
because they'd be able to do everything
by themselves what would even be the
point of that having the Avengers if you
had a character that was that powerful
that could fix everything by themselves
so that's why the amount of power that
it takes to power her to her binary
cosmic level form is so great that you
just don't find that everywhere
so even if she were to soak some quantum
energy and power herself up it still
wouldn't be enough to take her to binary
form the world breaker Hulk that
everybody is hoping to see during
Avengers 4 I think is gonna be closer to
professor Hulk and even though in the
comics he just keeps getting stronger
and stronger the matter he gets they
have not tested the limit of that in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and even if
you consider his fight with fan OHS at
the beginning of infinity war of version
of that I think if you take the Russos
at their word at Hulk's performance and
what they were doing with that character
he was just so surprised by how powerful
fan dose was that he was caught off
guard if you gave them enough time he
probably would have been able to get
even matter and take fan OHS down but
the problem when you're fighting
somebody with Infinity stones is it's
hard to quantify their power
it's like Dragonball power scaling is
that sometimes it doesn't totally make
sense so that's why we'll probably see
99% of her abilities during the Captain
Marvel movie they'll probably say that
1% ultra instinct whatever you want to
call it mastered ultra instinct Captain
Marvel finishing move for Avengers 4
just to give you something to look
forward to hopefully that helps explain
a little bit why people are saying she's
so powerful because it does have to make
sense like Thor's power comes from his
people he's a real God in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe they canonized the
Thor force which is what it's called
when he takes over for Odin and sort of
absorbs Odin's power we're not too far
off from getting that Captain Marvel
trailer if I hear any news about that I
will totally post in the video but
because that Spider Man ps4 game is
coming out my non-spoilery review of
that will post tomorrow and I'm doing
giveaways in my Marvel videos all you
have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video leave all your requests for videos
in the comments below click here for
that brand new Shazam Black Adam video
and click here for brand new Avengers 4
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]